you probably know i'm not a fan of
disney or star wars uh and uh had never
seen the mandalorian or heard the name
gina carano
before yesterday what i learned about
miss carano though from reading
mainstream media
headlines and sifting through some of
the tweets under the
fire gina carano hashtag is that she's a
bigot
and a psychopath and a transphobe and an
anti-semite and a danger to herself and
others
i learned that she has now been booted
from her role on the mandalorian and
fired by disney
a cause for celebration i'm told after
an instagram post
that became sort of the final straw that
post has been reported by media outlets
like usa today and chicago sun times
as straightforwardly anti-semitic not
even like
some people claim it's anti-semitic or
some people see it as anti-semitic but
that it is just simply anti-semitic
this gina chrono person i mean she seems
like a pretty unsafe character
anti-semitic posts transphobic
she's bigoted all these things pretty
pretty bad
or she would seem that way to anyone
stupid enough
to still take the popular narrative at
face value the rest of us
will want to do a little bit more
research into the topic and form our own
judgments
it doesn't it doesn't take much research
to discover that the narrative
is once again completely and utterly
bogus
so what did the now deleted instagram
post that has been dubbed anti-semitic
by not only the media but her former
employer actually say
i mean lucasfilm sent out a statement
declaring that carano's
quote social media posts denigrating
people based on their cultural and
religious religious beliefs are
abhorrent
and unacceptable abhorrent and
unacceptable
is there any basis for this charge
well decide for yourself the post in
question appears to be a screenshot of
somebody else's post which karano had
reposted to her own instagram it says
this is what it says
jews were beaten in the streets not by
nazi soldiers but by their neighbors
even by children because history is
edited most people today don't realize
that to get to the point where nazi
soldiers could easily round up thousands
of jews
the government first made their own
neighbors hate them simply for being
jews
how is that any different from hating
someone for their political views
that's it that was the post anti-semitic
denigrating people based on their
cultural and religious identities what
it's it's the it's the opposite of that
actually
she is comparing our current political
environment to nazi germany
in an unfavorable way she's not saying
it's good that it's like this
and by the way if making a nazi
comparison is anti-semitic
then everyone in the country is a raging
anti-semite
as everyone knows nazi comparisons are
the most common rhetorical strategy
in any debate they may be way overused
and they are
and overwrought and they often are but
there's nothing shocking or offensive or
abhorrent about this one single example
of a thing that you can find
in a billion other places on the
internet and everyone has done it
jews and non-jews alike we have all been
guilty apparently
at various points of making nazi
analogies
in fact as nazi analogies go this this
one gets closer to the truth than most
i mean she's correct that the lead up to
any holocaust level atrocity always
involves the dehumanization of a certain
group of people
now i would say this has already
happened in this country to the unborn
60 million have been slaughtered because
of it
is it happening to conservatives too
well we're not being rounded up and
executed obviously but her point is
simply to show
where trends can lead when taken to
their most violent
extreme now say what you want about that
but if you say that she's denigrating
jews somehow then
well you're lying straight up
and i hope she has a team of lawyers
ready to sue lucasfilm for this
defamation that is defamation of
character
they accused her of doing something that
she absolutely did not do it's not even
that you can
you could interpret it in that way you
cannot
at no literate person could read what
she posted and see that as her
denigrating jews
we could of course sit here all day
pulling examples of leftists making nazi
and holocaust comparisons
they spent four years doing it
relentlessly every day
and donald trump never staged any mass
executions of any political dissidents
yet they didn't stop anyone from calling
him hitler we could even pull examples
of of other disney actors on the same
show
making nazi comparisons pedro pascal um
another actor on the mandalorian tweeted
in 2018
uh hashtag this is america
and you can see it here it says he says
this is america hashtag with a picture
of jews and concentration camps in 1944
um on top of a picture of the infamous
kids in cages in america in 2018
so there's the nazi comparison except
that as far as i could tell
that's not really from 2018 it's from
2010 and it's not from america either
well minor details oh and by the way
it's it's also those kids are also not
in a cage you could tell if you look at
the far left
end of the of the photo there that
there's
there's a large opening where the kids
can come and go
so it's a picture of kids in cages in
america in 2018
except it's not from 2018 it's not from
america and they're not in a cage
hey other than that i'd say it's
correctly labeled
in any case despite common
misconceptions trump was not rounding up
and executing immigrants
he detained them as obama did and as
biden is doing right now
and then if they were here illegally he
sent them home
that is not at all even slightly
analogous to nazi germany
no part of that is the same
the only similarity is that both
involved governments
and both involved some form of
detainment so by pedro's logic
every government then is effectively a
nazi government including the current
one running this country right now
but he wasn't fired for that the reason
has a lot to do with those pronouns that
you can see
in his bio um which function like the
the lamb's blood on the door
signaling for the angel of cancellation
to pass over
incidentally that's one of the other
offensive things that carano did or or
didn't do
one of the straws before the final one
apparently she refused to put pronouns
in her bio
now that's really one of the things that
made people mad at her is that she
didn't have pronouns in her bible
and then when she finally did um
in in reference to rt r2d2 she she said
that her pronouns were boop
beep boop which is which is pretty funny
but you're not allowed to joke about the
sacred pronouns we must not joke
that that is heresy one of several
heretical
outbursts from carano whose real sin
whose only sin as far as the left is
concerned
is that she doesn't agree with them
she has a number of views that do not
align with leftism
she expressed those views and that's why
they wanted her destroyed and ultimately
they got what they wanted what do we
learned from this
well um nothing really i mean we learned
what we already knew that we live in a
time
when rigid ideological conformity is
demanded carano
isn't being shipped off to a death camp
of course but her case her case does
demonstrate the sort of dehumanization
that you do find in our culture she's
being lied about
and defamed and the people doing it
know what they're doing and they don't
care
they can look at that post she put up
there they know that's not anti-semitic
and they also know that
they themselves have made exactly that
kind of point a million times
but they're defaming her anyway they
honestly believe that anyone who
disagrees with them
deserves that treatment you can lie
about them and destroy them it doesn't
matter
they do not recognize any kind of moral
obligation or standard when dealing with
the cultural heretics
you can shut them down shut them up cast
them out lie about them that's the only
goal
so ironically the point corona was
making in her supposedly offensive
instagram post
has been aptly illustrated by the
outrage response to it
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated